ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen
herrscht Chaos in Putins Armee diese
Frage stellen sich heute viele denn nach
der Wagner Revolte wurde jetzt der
generalar marmageddon genannte Sergej
sorowikin festgenommen das berichten
zumindest verschiedene Medien
übereinstimmend es vizekommandeur der
russischen Truppen in der Ukraine und
jetzt ist die große Frage wie viel
Unruhe löst das alles aus
vier Tage nachdem die Wagner Söldner den
Aufstand geprobt hatten zeigt sich Kreml
Chef Putin heute ungewohnt volksnah das
Staatsfernsehen filmte den russischen
Präsidenten in Dagestan inmitten von
Fans
ja und was mit ihm hier ist das bleibt
unterdessen wie gesagt unklar Vize
Generalstabschef zur verhaftet worden
sein es wird spekuliert er habe vorab
vom wagneraufstand gewusst
darüber sprechen wir mit dem Russland
und Militärexperten Nico lange her lange
schön dass Sie bei uns im Stream wieder
dabei sind in dem Video dass wir gerade
gesehen haben da sehen wir ihn ja am
Samstag noch wie er den wagner-chef
brigoshi aufgefordert hat den Aufstand
zu beenden jetzt soll er also
festgenommen worden sein was bedeutet
das alles
das Video am Samstag wird der schon
etwas seltsam aber suche Wiking hat
vielleicht dieses Video aufgenommen weil
ihm gerade ihm ja nachgesagt wurde dass
er eine gewisse Verbindung zu der
wagnergruppe und zu diesen Kämpfern hat
und dass sie vielleicht auf ihn am
ehesten hören würden ganz sicher nicht
auf Schalke und gerassimov dir als
absolutes Feindbild gelten für die
wagnerkämpfer was jetzt mit so Wiking
passiert darüber gibt es viele Gerüchte
jedenfalls hat man seit Tagen nichts von
ihm gehört und er ist wohl auch nicht zu
Hause gewesen einige Zeitungen
bestätigen dass er verhaftet wurde aber
es ist ganz schwer Informationen zu
bekommen aus Moskau es ist aber auch
nicht so einfach damit jetzt umzugehen
so wir gehen hat große Erfolge in Syrien
aus russischer Perspektive erreicht er
hat viel Ansehen bei vielen in Russland
also den kann man jetzt auch nicht
einfach so verschwinden lassen
möglicherweise wird er ja auch nur
verhört befragt und taucht dann wieder
auf der Bild Speicher auf das ist
rätselhaft was in Russland gerade vor
sich geht wenn ihr fragen habt an Nico
lange dann schreibt sie gerne in die
Kommentare oder wenn ihr die App nutzt
an die eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse ZDF
heute - live at zdf.de ich gucke gerade
mal in die Chats und hier stellt zum
Beispiel jemand die Frage namens ische
auf Youtube wer wird nun dieses
Machtvakuum von surowikin füllen
ja die
Aufräumarbeiten in den Streitkräften
versuchen ja der sehr erfahrene
verteilungsminister Sergej scheu und der
generalstaatschefs grassimo für sich zu
lösenhof war zwischendurch schon mal weg
dann ist er jetzt wieder da und scheu Go
ist ein ganz gewiefter Taktiker der
schon seit der Zeit von parisien sich an
der Spitze hält in unterschiedlichen
Funktionen und den man offensichtlich
nicht so einfach absetzen kann
möglicherweise versuchen die jetzt auch
noch Rechnungen zu begleichen den zu
schwächen oder aus dem Weg zu räumen für
die Ukraine ist das aber insgesamt die
Botschaft in Russland geht's jetzt um
die Frage wer ist loyal nicht so stark
um die Frage wer ist kompetent das ist
ja vielleicht für die Ukraine eine
Chance die man nutzen kann bevor wir
auch auf den militärischen Aspekt dieser
Frage blicken bleiben wir noch mal ganz
kurz beim Personal sozusagen der
militärischen Führung da gab es auch ein
Bild am Samstag wo sich brigoshi gezeigt
hat mit dem stellvertretenden
verteidigungsmin ister und dem
stellvertretenden Leiter des Militär
Geheimdienstes hier sehen wir die drei
noch mal am Samstag noch in scheinbar
trauter Dreisamkeit was sehen wir hier
für Allianzen und jetzt mit dem quasi
niedergeschlagenen Aufstand wie geht das
jetzt weiter
hat ja diese Leute getroffen in Roßdorf
am Dorn am Samstagvormittag wo er
einfach dort reinmarschiert ist in
dieses Hauptquartier von dort wird der
gesamte Krieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine geführt und hat im Grunde gesagt
guten Morgen mein Name ist bregorian ich
übernehme jetzt hier mal die Kontrolle
zusammen mit meinen Kämpfern und dann
haben die sich dort unterhalten man
merkt dem stellvertretenden
verteilungsminister und auch dem anderen
russischen Vertreter an dass die
offensichtlich darauf warten dass sie
Ansagen bekommen aus Moskau der
verteilungsminister scholge und der
generalstaatschef gerassimo sollen
vorher genau dort gewesen sein die sind
aber verschwunden bevor vorher kam und
er hat ja darum gebeten mit ihnen zu
sprechen und das hat er dann zu dem
Zeitpunkt in diesem Gespräch nicht
erreichen dass deswegen gesagt okay dann
müssen eben Truppen von mir nach Moskau
ziehen die kennen sich natürlich alle
gut weil der insbesondere der russische
Militär Geheimdienst groß doch die
wagnergruppe angeheuert hatte damit
drecksaufgaben erledigt werden können
damit Dinge erledigt werden können die
man eigentlich normal nicht tun kann und
die man so hinstellen kann als wären es
gar nicht die Russen sondern es werden
es irgendwelche privaten Dinge putinette
mittlerweile zugenommen zugegeben dass
die Finanzierung der wagnergruppe immer
aus dem russischen Staatshaushalt
erfolgt ist und die war so was wie eine
wie eine verlängerte Werkbank des
russischen Militärgeheimdienstes
deswegen ist es nicht verwunderlich dass
die sich alle untereinander kennt die
große Frage die wir uns heute stellen
auch in diesem Stream ist die ob Chaos
in dem russischen Militär herrscht wie
ist Ihre Antwort
und zumindest sortieren sich die
Loyalitäten und jeder versucht irgendwie
seine eigene Position zu sichern keiner
weiß wem er vertrauen kann und will man
nicht vertrauen kann und wenn man das
Treffen von Putin mit seinen mit seinem
Sicherheitskabinett gesehen hat der
Herbst der eine finstere eiseskalte
Stimmung keiner weiß wer stand auf
welcher Seite und jeder versucht
irgendwie nicht aufzufallen also da
läuft hinter den Kulissen glaube ich
viel und sicherlich wird Putin auch sich
die Frage stellen wem kann ich
eigentlich noch Vertrauen in meinen
eigenen Streitkräften weil ja keiner
sich gegen die wagnergruppe in die
Bresche geworfen hat alle irgendwie
nicht erreichbar waren an diesem
Wochenende oder sich weggeduckt haben
möglicherweise ist da die Verhaftung von
Zoro weggehen erst der Anfang eines
Prozesses
dann schauen wir inwiefern das alles
Auswirkungen hat auf den Krieg in der
Ukraine und die militärischen Positionen
dort Herr Lange wir sprechen gleich mit
ihnen weiter ich möchte aber erstmal
meinen Kollegen mit ins Boot holen der
in der Ukraine vor Ort ist und zwar ist
das Sarah Hassan Sade der in saporicia
heute gedreht hat aber vor allem auch
dort gute Einblicke bekommen hat wie die
Situation an der Front ist daran was
sind die Informationen die du hast wie
erfolgreich ist die Ukraine im Moment
ja die das Militär hat heute bekannt
gegeben dass die Ukraine wieder
vorrücken konnte allerdings waren die
gebietske Gewinne relativ gering bei der
bertjansk Front die weiter im Osten
liegt soll es sich dabei um 1.300 Meter
gehalten gehandelt haben ich hatte
mit Soldaten einer Spezialeinheit von
denen konnte ich erfahren dass die
Kämpfe hier in der Nähe die sage ich mal
die Front Richtung militopol abbilden
dass die dort sehr sehr schwer sind und
das Vorkommen äußerst ja
anstrengend ist für die Soldaten
anstrengend diesen Krieger aber sie
kommen kaum voran weil die Minenfelder
im Vorfeld so gelegt sind dass ähm sie
einfach nur ganz langsam vorrücken
dadurch werden sie zu einem Ziel für die
russische Armee zu einem leichten Ziele
es gibt eine Luft Überlegenheit die auch
auf der russischen Seite überlegt und
viele Stellungen sind sehr stark
gesichert sie sprechen auch davon dass
Schützengräben zum Teil mit Betonplatten
abgedeckt sind und von daher für
die Drohnen dann nicht erreichbar sind
es ist für sie äußerst schwierig sie
sprachen von vier Linien die zweite und
die dritte Verteidigungslinien der
Russen sei noch stärker gesichert als
die erste und die erste haben sie noch
nicht erreicht
da was benötigen denn die Soldaten
besonders was wird im Moment am meisten
gebraucht
sie haben gesagt ein Game changer wäre
die Luft Unterstützung sowohl
Flugabwehrwaffen in ausreichender Zahl
sowie auch der Einsatz von Kampfjets das
würde die das gesamte gefechtsbild
drehen
aber die die haben sie noch nicht und
ähm von daher sind sie auf dieses
langsame Vorgehen in relativ
ungeschützten Raum angewiesen und sie
sehen sich richtig nach diesen Waffen
sie sagen das ist das was man braucht
vor allem wenn sie an die zweite und
dann die dritte Verteidigungslinie der
Russen denken da lass uns noch kurz über
grammatance sprechen da hatte haben die
russischen Truppen jetzt nach Angaben
nur militärische Ziele beschossen und
dabei zwei ukrainische generelle und
dutzende Militärs getötet das ist die
russische Sicht auf die Dinge die
ukrainische sieht anders aus dort
berichtet man von mindestens 12 Menschen
die ums Leben kamen weil auch ein
Restaurant das offenbar sehr gut besetzt
war getroffen worden ist welche
Informationen hast du dazu
zum einen hat die Ukraine heute bekannt
gegeben dass sie den Drahtzieher
verhaftet und verhört hätten und dass
dieser auch zu eingestanden hätte dieses
Restaurant ausgespioniert zu haben und
diese Informationen nach Russland
weitergeleitet hat zum anderen wird
immer mehr über die Opfer bekannt dieses
narrativ das Russland militärische Ziele
anvisiere und das zivile Opfer
eigentlich nur
Kollateralschäden werden hält sich schon
länger nicht mehr aber in diesem Fall
ganz besonders nicht es ist ja eben habe
ich erfahren dass eine
literarische Konferenz in kremators
stattfand mit einer kolumbianischen
Delegation auch die Waren in dem
Restaurant und eine ukrainische
Schriftstellerin ist schwer verletzt und
ähm liegt im Krankenhaus und ihre
Kollegen bangen und mir Leben waren
unter der Opfer schon sehr viele
Zivilisten
vielen Dank
in die Ukraine danke schön nach
saporicia
dann blicken wir weiterhin auf das
militärische Geschehen in der Ukraine
und holen wieder Nico lange den Militär
und Russland Experten mit dazu Herr
Lange wenn ich hier in die Chats gucke
dann Fragen hier verschiedene User einer
zum Beispiel ob das jetzt nicht die
beste Zeit für die Ukraine ist im Sinne
von man kann die Anzeichen des Chaos in
der russischen Armee nutzen um
möglicherweise jetzt erfolgreiche
Vorstöße zu erzielen sehen Sie das auch
so
ja und nein also man weiß nicht an
vielen Frontabschnitten was die
russischen Soldaten überhaupt Wissen
über die Lage in Russland und über diese
Auseinandersetzung den sind die
Mobiltelefone abgenommen worden die
kriegen sowieso schon immer eine
ordentliche Dosis Propaganda so nach dem
Motto sie würden dort gegen Nazis
kämpfen müssen und müssen die die
Ukraine von den Nazis befreien also da
weiß man nicht was die mitbekommen und
die militärische Lage verändert sich ja
nicht einfach so also die Minenfelder
von denen gerade gesprochen worden ist
die Luft Überlegenheit der russischen
Seite all das ist ja weiter da und macht
eigentlich in den meisten
Frontabschnitten nur ein ganz langsames
und methodisches Vorgehen möglich da
ändert sich jetzt durch die Situation
erst mal nichts wenn das länger anhält
und
die Dinge noch weiter in Bewegung
geraten in Russland dann könnte das
vielleicht noch einen Unterschied machen
aber es gibt eine Stelle wo man schon
sieht dass es ein Unterschied macht und
zwar ist das sind bachmut das ist sollte
es nicht genau gerade Nachfragen wir
haben eine Karte vorbereitet da kann man
auch noch mal ein bisschen für die
Userinnen und User ein bisschen mehr
noch mal Orientierung schaffen hier
sehen wir bachmut und bitte Ihre
Einschätzung zur Lage dort unterlange
achmut ist ja in monatelang Kämpfe unter
extremen Verlusten von der wagnergruppe
erobert worden und dann ist die
wagnergruppe dort abgezogen worden und
die Stellung wurden von russischen
Streitkräften besetzt die sind aber
häufig nicht so leistungsfähig auch
nicht so erfahren vielleicht auch nicht
so Gruppe los wie die wagnerkämpfer und
die Ukraine versucht dort Gegenangriffe
und da gab es heute mehrere Meldungen
dass die Ukraine sowohl nördlich von
bachmut als auch südlich von bachmut
wichtige Höhenzüge erreicht hat und wenn
man auf diesen Höhenzügen erstmal drauf
ist dann kann man natürlich nach unten
gegen die russischen Streitkräfte viel
besser wirken und die Russen sind da
massiv unter Druck haben wohl jetzt auch
Reserven dazu gezogen und wenn der
ukrainische Generalstab das hat er heute
getan meldet man ging ja auf breiter
frontan der sich ja sonst zurückhält
dann scheint es sozusagen dass in
bachmut die Ukrainer da einige wichtige
Erfolge erzielen können und das
vielleicht vieles was die wagnergruppe
unter hohen Verlusten in monatelangen
Kämpfen erobert hat dann in wenigen
Tagen wieder verloren ist für die Russen
dann lassen Sie uns noch auf einen
anderen Frontabschnitt schauen und zwar
weiter im Süden des Landes in der Nähe
von herson dort gibt es einen besonderen
Übergang über den nipro und zwar die
antoniefka Brücke und auch hier wird
berichtet dass die Ukraine
einige Erfolge erzielen können hier
sehen wir es auch noch mal lokalisiert
im Süden der Ukraine und hier sehen wir
auch es gibt berichtete dass sich dort
ukrainische Soldaten verschanzt haben
und auch mit Schnellboten den Fluss
überquert haben und auf die russische
Seite gefeiert haben was wissen sie
darüber herange
ja dass die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
auf dem linken Ufer des Flusses sind
also auf dem östlichen Ufer das kann man
bestätigen die Landschaft dort besteht
aber sehr stark aus Sumpfgebieten die
sind auch immer noch sumpfig auch wenn
der Fluss jetzt durch den Abfluss aus
dem staubbecken
geringeren Pegel hat und das ist nicht
so unbedingt geeignet um da jetzt ein
Brückenkopf zu etablieren also unter
weitere Truppen aufmarschieren zu lassen
von denen mit denen man dann weiter
vorstoßen kann da sind vier fünf
Kilometer Sumpfgebiet erst noch zu
überwinden es gibt dort eine Ortschaft
und lisky heißt die zu der die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte offensichtlich
vorgedrungen sind und wo es jetzt
weitere Kämpfe gibt aber zumindest ist
es schon mal eine interessante Nachricht
dass man auch auf dem linken Ufer des
Depot an dieser Stelle jetzt ukrainische
Streitkräfte sieht ob sie das ausbauen
können da bin ich ehrlich gesagt eher
skeptisch
verlange im Moment gibt es einen
EU-Gipfel in Brüssel da wird auch die
Lage in Russland nach dem Wagner
Aufstand mit großem Interesse verfolgt
und vor allem auch mit großer Sorge wenn
man an die polnische Grenze zu Russland
blickt nachdem es nämlich jetzt Berichte
gibt dass die wagnergruppe dort in
Weißrussland neue stationiert werden
soll welche Gefahr geht von den Kämpfern
aus die ja als besonders brutal gelten
äh den Blick aus Brüssel hat Florian neu
Hand für uns
die Frage an die Menschen vor den
Mikrofonen ist seit dem Wochenende
dieselbe was ist in Russland wirklich
los in Brüssel beim EU-Gipfel gibt es
heute viele Theorien und eine offene
Antwort ich bin lieber ehrlich ich weiß
das Politiker immer sagen ja ja
kompliziert mal nein keine Ahnung oder
droht eine neue Front in Belarus
südöstlich der Hauptstadt Minsk ein
bisher verlassener Militärstützpunkt
Satellitenaufnahmen von Samstag zeigen
dass die Gebäude noch leer standen auf
Aufnahmen von Dienstag sind neue
Strukturen zu erkennen womöglich für
Söldner der wagnertruppe das nährt
sorgen in angrenzenden EU-Staaten sorgen
die der Bundeskanzler zu zerstreuen
versucht wir müssen genau beobachten was
da geschieht und in welcher Dimension
das der Fall ist in der NATO haben wir
uns Beistand versprochen jeder Angriff
auf nato-teritoris ist eine Sache die
wir gemeinsam beantworten werden passend
dazu Besuch von NATO Generalsekretär
Jens solltenberg beim EU-Gipfel später
versichert man dem zugeschalteten
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski der
Ukraine so lange beizustehen wie nötig
ja Nico lange ist bei uns in der Sendung
militär-experte und Russland Kenner Herr
lange bevor wir über die Hilfen noch mal
sprechen erst noch mal zur Lage an der
Grenze zwischen Polen und Weißrussland
da schreiben jetzt auch viele Userinnen
und User im Hinblick darauf z.B Michael
Rossmann könnte es sein dass der Putsch
eine doppeltaktik ist und in
Wirklichkeit die Wagner sollten nun ihre
Kräfte in Bella Rust sammeln und von
dort Kiew angreifen und noch eine Frage
dazu haben die Ukraine genug Kräfte für
einen zwei Fronten Krieg
also die Antwort auf beide Fragen ist
ich sehe überhaupt keine Gefahr dass
jetzt Wagner Kräfte von Belarus aus Kiew
angreifen könnten
ich glaube auch überhaupt gar nicht dass
dieser Putschversuch irgendwie gespielt
war oder dass das ein Plan war um die
nach Belarus zu kriegen also die hätten
ja nach Belarus gehen können wo ist das
Problem ob die jemals in Belarus
ankommen halt ist sogar für fraglich
weil das sind ja individuelle Angebote
die Putin gemacht hat an die
wagnerkämpfer sie könnten sich
entscheiden ob sie entweder nach Belarus
gehen oder nach Hause oder ob sie in die
russischen Streitkräfte integriert
werden können ähm da weiß man ja gar
nicht wie sich die einzelnen Personen
entscheiden das ist jedenfalls nicht so
dass die gesamte wagnergruppe genommen
wird und nach Bäder rausgebracht wird
zumal völlig unklar ist was die da
überhaupt tun sollen für eine Angriff
auf Kiew da bräuchte man eine riesige
Anzahl von Kräften die Ukraine haben
damit mittlerweile gestaffelte
Verteidigungsstellung das kann man also
mit ein paar tausend WAG Kämpfern nicht
bewerkstelligen und auch was einen
Angriff auf nato-gebiet von Belarus
anbetrifft würde ich mir da nicht die
größten Sorgen machen in Bezug auf die
wagnergruppe das ganze ist vor allen
Dingen eine schlechte Botschaft für
Belarus also Lukaschenko versucht zwar
zu sagen dass man die zeitweise dort
aufnimmt aber wenn er die dort erstmal
hätte würde er sie nicht mehr los und
die würden natürlich auch auf ihn ein
bisschen aufpassen und er hat schon mit
der Lagerung von russischen Atomwaffen
sehr stark an Souveränität eingebüßt mit
den wagnerkräften würde er das noch mehr
tun und es ist auch für alle die eine
Veränderung von Belarus wollen natürlich
keine gute Botschaft wenn man jetzt
diese Söldner da hat die uns
Zweifelsfall dann für die russischen
Interessen und für Putin eher einstehen
würden als sich da irgendwie positiv
einzubringen in Belarus also die
schlechten Nachrichten hat vor allen
Dingen wieder raus
Herr Lange sie waren lange für die
Adenauer Stiftung in der Ukraine unter
anderem sie waren Staatssekretär im
Bundesverteidigungsministerium sind
jetzt für die Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz auch tätig sie
haben auch in St Petersburg waren sie
tätig also sie haben sehr sehr guten
Einblick in die Situation und auch in
die Bedürfnisse der Ukrainer wenn wir
darauf blicken dass in Brüssel jetzt
gerade wieder darüber gesprochen wird
was die Ukraine braucht was ist das aus
ihrer Sicht Dara Hass gerade gesagt aus
der Ukraine kommt der Wunsch nach mehr
Luftabwehr und Luftunterstützung und
hier fragen viele User ist es jetzt
nicht an der Zeit die F16 zu liefern
das ist schon lange an der Zeit die ab
16 zu liefern und das ist unverständlich
warum wir für alles immer so lange
brauchen ist gut dass wir schützen und
Kampfpanzer liefern haben wir aber viel
zu spät entschieden ist gut dass die F16
kommen werden aber auch das ist viel zu
spät entschieden worden jetzt dauert es
noch eine Weile um die logistische Kette
aufzubauen und die Piloten werden ja
schon seit einiger Zeit ausgebildet
deswegen bin ich zuversichtlich das ist
gar nicht mehr so lange dauern wird
einige Monate noch bis wir die
Unterstützung mit F16 sehen werden bei
der EU ist natürlich wichtig dass die EU
mit makrofinanziellen Hilfen also mit
Geld das letztlich den ukrainischen
Staatshaushalt stützt dafür sorgt dass
es der Grundlagen gibt es leben sie sind
ja viele Ukrainerinnen Ukraine
zurückgekehrt und die müssen ja
irgendwie leben können das muss auch
irgendwie eine wirtschaftliche Aktivität
geben Schulen müssen funktionieren
Infrastrukturen müssen funktionieren und
da spielt die EU eine ganz wichtige
Rolle und hat ja glücklicherweise gerade
entschieden dass in den nächsten vier
Jahren mit 50 Milliarden Euro die
Ukraine unterstützt werden soll das
halte ganz wichtig und die EU hat eine
neue Rolle eingenommen nämlich mit der
sogenannten friedensfazilität also einem
finanziellen Instrument waffenausrüstung
und Munition zu kaufen und das auch so
stark zu tun dass sogar die
Produktionskapazitäten erhöht werden
können vor allen Dingen bei Munition und
das halte ich für eine gute Entwicklung
weil wir diesen langen Krieg und die
Unterstützung der Ukraine in diesem
langen Krieg nur entscheiden können in
einem Sinne der Abwehr des russischen
Angriffes wenn jetzt auch genügend
produziert wird dass man in die Ukraine
ständig nachliefern kann dass die
Ukraine Ersatzteile bekommt und Munition
wenn die EU das noch ein bisschen
schneller machen würde wäre das noch
besser
eine letzte Frage aus der Community an
sie verlange Detlef Hammer fragt Herr
Lange wie wahrscheinlich ist ein
schnelles Ende des Krieges
ein schnelles Ende des Krieges wird
wahrscheinlicher in zwei Fällen ich
glaube ein Russland ohne Putin vor dem
man keine Angst haben sollte und wir
haben am Wochenende glaube ich ein
Vorgeschmack darauf gekriegt wie schnell
das eigentlich gehen könnte dass ich da
was verändert ein Russland ohne Putin
gebe jemanden neuen die Chance diesen
Krieg schnell zu beenden die Truppen
zurückzuziehen und etwas anderes
anzufangen also wir sollten da keine
Angst haben dass da irgendwas
schlimmeres passiert ich glaube
schlimmer als Putin kann es nicht werden
und die zweite Möglichkeit ist wenn die
Ukraine genügend Ausstattungen
Ausrüstung bekommt wenn wir nicht so
zögerlich und so schrittweise liefern
sondern uns mal entschlossen dahinter
klemmen und alles liefern was notwendig
ist dann wäre die Ukraine in der Lage
die Front zu durchbrechen und die
russischen Truppen letztlich zu
vertreiben und das ist ja letztlich auch
der Weg der zu einem nachhaltigen
Frieden führen könnte in beiden Fällen
gibt es Frieden nur wenn die russischen
Truppen das Gebiet der Ukraine wieder
verlassen dass aus meiner Sicht das was
wir unbedingt brauchen
vielen Dank Nicole lange dass sie mit
ihrer Expertise bei uns im Stream waren
danke schön
und ich sage auch danke im Namen des
ganzen Teams und besonders gefreut hat
uns natürlich einen Kommentar von
Oberberg über Youtube ZDF heute danke
dass ihr uns die Möglichkeit für Fragen
gibt wir danken euch dass ihr fragt und
mit kommentiert und freuen uns aufs
nächste Mal macht's gut bis dann tschüss